welcome back and we are joined by the
tournament winner magnus carson magnus
congratulations
uh and my first question to you has to
be a record eight victory here in
vikenzi what does it mean to you
uh well i obviously had the previous
record
also
but overall now i've uh
get my record of winning
the tournament more times than not which
was something that i was aiming for
for you this year but
first first of all i'm just very happy
to have been able to play the tournament
and um to perform
very very well
and while you're talking about those
eight victories is there any of them
that stands out more than others or are
they all equally special
um i do feel that most of my wins were
pretty uh pretty good and pretty
clean uh but i did enjoy the game
against mamadiarov a lot i thought that
was probably my best game
and uh obviously the game today was was
nice but it clearly was not fabian at
his best
and
the conditions were sort of um
pretty easy after after a while
since i felt that the exchange stack was
pretty obvious i did find some good
moves
after that but
i don't think i did anything
particularly difficult
the circumstances of the game were of
course different with you knowing you
would get the free point against daniel
tomorrow
how did that impact your preparation did
you feel it gave you more freedom more
liberties to maybe play for more
um yes knowing that this would be
my my last game i had some
hopes
that i could perhaps play for more
indeed uh today especially after
yesterday was
pretty uh
was a pretty disappointing
performance
i really wanted to end on uh on a high
note
today it was not like i was
setting out to take massive risks
but i at least kind of
wanted to
play a little bit
and
[Music]
he wanted to play obviously as well
but sometimes when you're a bit out of
out of shape this can
[Music]
this can
yeah
this can lead to pretty bad results and
um that's what happened for him you
singled out the win against my media if
i guess there was another win that
surely is quite dear to you it was the
one that started your winning wins
against anish gear it was your first uh
classical
win against him here in vikenze was that
a special moment for you as well
um sure there have been some some near
misses against him uh ever since i i
lost that
infamous game back in uh 20
2011 but
i i'm
obviously
with him starting to
to win a few games
after a while that was
that was pretty crucial but
then again i i didn't feel that i did
anything anything special in
in in that game uh but i did send him
some
some problems that he failed to cope
with in in the opening but um
um
but but yeah as i said i felt overall
most of my wins were
pretty pretty good a couple of those
that we just talked about came from the
catalan an opening which lately in your
hand seems to have become a deadly
weapon can you tell us a little bit
about what's your aspiration behind that
and you're feeling towards the cuddling
opening
um
yeah so one of the
one of the main points of my preparation
for the match against the punisher was
to feel comfortable sacrificing upon
in the catalan because that's something
that i always kind of struggle with
um
and
obviously i was helped by by duboff
there
since that his is his
specialty and i feel like i already
i'm already improving there
um for instance against mamidyarov i i
sacrificed
upon
there
for not too obvious com compensation
uh and i was just feeling feeling good
like it was like it was normal so i'm
definitely i'm getting the getting the
taste for for the opening do you think
that's also going to be shaping the near
future do you feel like you're a
trailblazer in that sense that's always
been quite popular but
do you feel you're breathing a new life
into the opening
um no
um catalan is
one of the top openings by uh by neural
networks so it's not going to be a
surprise to anybody
well we're looking at your coach peter
heiner nielsen who's standing in the
corner but i'm sure he has something to
do with it magnus let's briefly talk
about uh vikanze you've played here 18
times
a lot of your life time spent here in
this coastal village what is it that
makes you enjoy being here so much
well there are a few things
obviously there is tradition which which
helps
um
but i think most of all
um the the format
uh playing so many different
players is
is uh is unique and playing against kind
of a varied
field
um
that's
something
that is unique to this tournament you
don't get that really anywhere
anywhere else
um
and uh
i don't know
the tradition part again i always feel
good coming here it's always
um
yeah it's so it's so it's always
always welcome i'm always kind of able
to
um to focus
here um and um
yeah this this time even though there
was
there was covet which is of course
unfortunate so that nobody can
can really come
uh and watch um it didn't really affect
my preparation and everything that
that that much
my daily routine was pretty much the
same probably as it would have been even
with
a lot of
people here
and i think i just managed to to focus
really really
really really well
it's interesting what you're saying and
of course we hope that next year we'll
be able to have the amateur players and
the spectators uh back is it something
that you missed do you like in general
playing in front of many fans
i think
as a chess player you obviously enjoy
people being there to
sort of appreciate what you're
what you're doing but
clearly for me there are some
benefits as well since
i can
uh
i can be um
sort of a little more more free but um
yeah i hope that people will be back
next year absolutely just a last couple
of questions uh recently you stated that
uh your next big goal is to work your
way up to 2 900
rating in classical what's your
approach to how to get there are you
planning to play a lot or
what's the game strategy
i'm
not necessarily planning to play a lot
of tournaments
what i will say is
and what i kind of emphasized when
i i set myself that goal is that i have
to be on top every time that i play
uh fully just fully focused
um and to always be at my best and
this i think i managed
um very well here
um it's not like i had a huge
surplus of energy i don't think anybody
does at this point
um
but i think
i really made the most of it i was
really disciplined
throughout the whole
um tournament and
i think that's that's that really is the
key to having any chance of attaining
that goal
um
how often
i play
um
that will see i don't have anything
particular plan before no which has at
the end of
may but
really just
being full of focus each time that i
play that's
that's the only thing that can
give me a chance of attaining that goal
very well we wish you best of luck with
that uh quest before i let you go magnus
there's one final question from a fan of
yours uh rebecca harris she is wondering
now that tata is over might there be
some more bullet matches on the horizon
for her
we'll see
we'll see magnus i'll let you go off do
you have any plans uh for tonight or
tomorrow will there be any celebration
um
i don't i don't know um i'm just really
happy
with the way things
ended
um
getting this last win in a good game mix
makes all the difference in the world
for me um and there'll be due time to
celebrate
if it's now or when i get home so that
part i'm not worried about great well
magnus thank you so much for your time
congratulations
on a brilliant performance your eighth
title here in tata thanks for joining us
and for now back to you dania
[Music]
you